moskau die hauptstadt russlands eine
millionen metropole mit zwei gesichtern
weltoffen und modern aber zugleich
streng und traditionell
wir begleiten sechs schweizer und
schweizerinnen die den mut hatten sich
im wilden osten niederzulassen
in dieser fremden geheimnisvollen welt
die unter präsident putin wieder an die
goldenen zeiten anknüpfen möchte weshalb
haben sich unsere schweizer diesen ort
ausgesucht wie heimisch fühlen sie sich
hier und mit welchen schwierigkeiten
sind sie täglich konfrontiert
traum oder albtraum abenteuer moskau
[Musik]
eine dateien tschechow rund 50 kilometer
südlich von moskau
willi berchtold hat ihre tochter vera zu
den schwiegereltern gebracht die
gebürtige bernerin arbeitet in der
schweizer botschaft
vera hat ferien deshalb wird sie bei den
großeltern bleiben
die stimmung ist gedrückt ich glaube ich
würde dachte sie was übergriff programm
helfern während schülers mann andré das
familienauto bildet kümmert sich die
schwiegermama und das leibliche wohl
[Gelächter]
sie weiß dass meine ganze so viel essen
wie sie bis gar nicht angefangen von
weder oder job ganz leicht beleidigt
über den 3 und eben die beste seit rund
15 jahren lebt sie in russland tochter
vera ist in der schweiz geboren
die wochenenden auf der datscha gehören
zum russischen lebensstil dass vera
fernab von ihrem geburtsland und unter
dem einfluss ihrer schwiegereltern
aufwächst ist für mich kein problem
der überlauf mit vier russische kultur
mit kommt ist es gut weil die kultur
mitbekommen aber es ist schon klar dass
er wirklich sagen welche ziele sie
sterben hat und wenn sie zurückkommt
helmut wege das bad wieder zusammen und
hat aber das ist nicht normal was hier
los ist und um die schweizerin peters
keine probleme
[Musik]
das hotel metropol im zentrum von moskau
zu zeiten des letzten russischen zaren
eine top adresse für gäste aus aller
welt
der 59 jährige dominique fouda ist hier
seit fünf jahren direktor seine freunde
nennen ihn speedy gonzales
sein auftrag dem hotel wieder das
renomee aus früheren zeiten zu verleihen
eine aufgabe die er auch seinen
mitarbeitern immer wieder einträgt hat
um dies zu erreichen musste der
hoteldirektor ganz von vorne anfangen
nicht organisationen vom service
mitarbeiter sind ziellos um einander
prof
alle die in dem problem gesehen ist das
komplett wie eine neue betrieb komplett
neu aufbauen das metropol einst gebaut
im bali wo stil hatte nach dem ende der
sowjetunion einen totalen zerfall erlebt
112 km entfernt im stadtteil goes up hat
naja dorothea kolde frühstückt mit ihrer
tochter sophie ein kleines ritual dass
mutter und tochter wenn immer möglich
zusammen genießen
die 53 jährige genferin lebt schon seit
25 jahren in moskau gekommen ist sie aus
liebe zu einem russen
dem vater von sophie nach schwierigen
zeiten hat sie sich aber erst kürzlich
von ihm getrennt jetzt müssen sich die
beiden frauen überlegen ob sie bleiben
oder in die schweiz zurückkehren sollen
meine besten freunde sind in der schweiz
wenn ich ans älterwerden denke sind
natürlich die freunde wichtig ich habe
in der schweiz freundschaften über die
jahre sogar noch stärker geworden sind
ich bin recht häufig dort und meine
freunde kommen
glücklicherweise können die zwei frauen
mit katze und hund hier wohnen bleiben
dorothea hat diese dreieinhalb zimmer
wohnung schon vor jahren gekauft
in der schweiz müsste sie eine wohnung
mieten die schweiz ist teuer ein
russisches geheilt hier ist zwar gut
aber in der schweiz könnte ich damit
nicht leben
manchmal denke ich das ist traurig ich
habe mein ganzes leben viel gearbeitet
und doch könnte ich mit meiner rente in
meiner heimat kaum leben
andererseits habe ich diese wahl damals
getroffen
das lässt sich jetzt nicht mehr ändern
tochter sophie ist doppelbürgerin
für sie ist klar wo sie hingehört ich
bin ja die russin ich studieren russland
ich spreche russisch
ich sehe aus wie eine russin es gibt
fast nur hunde denkt dass sich ausländer
an den moscow city das neue
geschäftszentrum der hauptstadt
die metropole hat sich seit dem
zusammenbruch der sowjetunion stark
verändert
er hat diesen wandel aus nächster nähe
miterlebt roland lay ist appenzeller und
arbeitet hier seit über 20 jahren
erfolgreich als bauunternehmer 140 km
sind also erfahrung zeigt wer die
zentrale szene buche das outing klima
also ich hab mir vorstelle woche lang
oder monate lagen amtlichen hat sie also
mit bass krise ganz lebensstil passt
natürlich als das ganze umfeld nur
entsprechen damit mache es ist das nicht
ankunft an der ersten baustelle die coop
gruppe hat in russland eine
supermarktkette eröffnet seitdem ukraine
konflikt leidet man hier unter den
wirtschaftssanktionen der eu aber der
tägliche konsum güter verkaufen sich
immer noch gut die bauarbeiten sind kurz
vor dem abschluss
die methoden jedoch ab und zu etwas
unkonventionell
das ist natürlich musste improvisiert
brite schied machen das mit schöner
spezielle geht da machen wir das ibc mit
russischer improvisation
aber es funktioniert umso sagt roland
ist sein eigener chef und beschäftigt
über 350 leute zweimal pro woche schaut
er hier vorbei auf jeder baustelle hat
er sein eigenes büro
ein jahr hat der bau des supermarktes
gedauert die kosten rund 14 millionen
euro
ley arbeitet ausschließlich für
auftraggeber aus westeuropa die vorteile
liegen auf der hand
also man kann der user wenn man der
baustelle abschließt alle pflichten
erfüllt also unternehmen der 100% geld
zahlte russischen auftraggeber sind da
zum teil hat mir noch andere kriterien
wo ihnen spielen und das ist natürlich
ein vorteil wenn man für westeuropäische
firmen neben den sanktionen der eu haben
auch der niedrige ölpreis und die
abwertung des rubels die
wirtschaftskrise verschärft dennoch
bleibt russland ein interessanter markt
george puppenbühne handelt hier seit
anfang der 90er jahre erfolgreich mit
maschinen
tochter swetlana hat ihre kindheit in
russland verbracht und spricht fließend
russisch
nach ihrem studium in zürich und london
unterstützt sie nun ihren vater und
bringt frischen wind ins geschäft
[Musik]
das projekt mit dem app store
abgewickelt haben das ist unter 7
millionen-euro-projekt der türkei nicht
das 2 2 als extremes verkauf stand das
spiel 86 getötet
mit einer runde sehr treffend gesagt hat
er sein fleisch nicht unbedingt das was
sie sich erträumt will sich im blog ins
netz geschafft worden
gerade mal ein paar meter weiter im
office ihres vaters verfolgt svitlana
ihre eigene geschäftsidee café im pott
sie führt hochwertigen kaffee direkt von
der plantage 1
die infrastruktur kommt vom vater bei
der akquisition und den handel hilft
neuerdings ihr australischer freund
kevin mit dass die beiden heute ein paar
sind verdanken sie ihre reiselust
ich habe es mit lama getroffen als wir
beide durch südamerika gereist sind
sie erzählte meere verrückte idee kaffee
nach russland zu importieren ich dachte
coole sache die cafés szene boomt
es ist wirklich unglaublich aber wenn
wir zu wenig verkauft wenn er das gefühl
hat dass es nicht so gut laufen wird und
darum dass ich so klicksafe.de meint
oder muss das langfristige und über
mehrere tage und vermisse ich das
einfach wenn man einen monat weniger
verkauft haben
dann nehme ich das jetzt hatte ich
glaube man muss auch geschafft die
kaffee in russland als sehr viel geboten
geduld und persönlichen kontakt mund zu
mund propaganda ist die beste werbung
deshalb organisiert die 26 jährige für
ihre kunden regelmäßig sogenannte cup
ins bei denen neue kaffee sorten
getestet und geschäftsbeziehungen
gepflegt werden können
beim handel mit rohstoffen ist viel geld
im spiel
das startkapital für den ersten
container hat vater george
bereitgestellt doch svitlana ist auf
gutem weg ihre schulden zurückzuzahlen
und jetzt haben und ich mache das
einfach gern im prinzip egal was ich
verkaufe ich halte einfach es geschafft
wo man wirklich die länder muss reise wo
genau so wenig entwickelt sind wenn
nicht nur wenige entwickelt wie russland
man muss der dax mit der bahn verhandeln
wenn man direkt auf rohstoffhandel vor
allem das produkt wie graf ich halte
einfach sehr komplex und sehr spannend
sehr interessant
domenico da der hoteldirektor des
metropolis will seine belegschaft zeigen
wie die zimmer innovation läuft die
zimmer sollen größer und luxuriöser
werden
am ende soll die rechnung trotzdem
aufgehen
[Musik]
210 metern hinten ordentlich und wieder
ist ein zweites doppelzimmer und die
renovation darf den betrieb des hotels
nicht beeinträchtigen
diese vorgabe hat dominique vom
hotelbesitzer erhalten
offenbar gelingt der betrieb rentiert
endlich das war in den ersten jahren
nicht der fall mittlerweile ganz viel
besser 2014/2015 milliarden fließen
natürlich gemacht hätte mit den
sanktionen und mit max verlosung oder
eine show sehen hält die ca
also ich mache mir inneren summe 2014
werden zusammenhangs von moment
[Musik]
russland blickt auf eine
jahrhundertealte geschichte zurück ein
einschneidendes ereignis der zweite
weltkrieg
der sieg über den deutschen faschismus
hat sich tief in die russische seele
gegeben
der neunte mai das kriegsende ist darum
bis heute der wichtigste feiertag
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die parade zum roten platz ist der
emotionale höhepunkt das volk gedenkt er
im krieg gefallenen verwandten
mittendrin chili peppers und ehemann
andre die beiden hobbyfotografen haben
ein faible für folkloristische motive
für juli ist es ein anlass mal wieder
über ihre eigenen wurzeln nachzudenken
er hat also mit vielleicht gestreckt hat
dass man sachen die nicht passieren darf
aber man macht es geht ganz gut
julis ehemann andré hat aus liebe zu
seiner frau sogar deutsch gelernt der
pr-experte kann sich den großen
emotionen am heutigen tag nicht
entziehen
[Musik]
ich glaube das gefühl dass du deine
familie dein land verteidigt passt ist
ein wichtiges gefühl ich fühle dass ich
da auf der straße sein sollte damit sich
diese emotionen irgendwie mitfühlen kann
mit den leuten die krieg als persönliche
tragödie erlebt hatten
russland hat unter putin seinen
nationalstolz wiedergefunden eine
entwicklung die im ausland oft skepsis
und kritik auslöst das volk leichtigkeit
grundsätzlich für das ist das positiv
für und es ist verdammt schwierig wenn
es in nationalismus umschlags und strom
großen abzugrenzen und landete dann
natürlich sehr aufmerksam und sauber mit
eiligen maße besorgt was ist da passiert
[Musik]
in moskau leben über zwölf millionen
menschen viele von ihnen sind mit ihrem
präsidenten zufrieden
die versorgungslage es besser zu
sowjetzeiten die stadt freundlicher und
sicherer
nur wer sich mit dem präsidenten anlegt
bekommt dessen ganze härte zu spüren
an warmen moskauer tagen fährt dorothea
gerne mit dem fahrrad zur botschaft wenn
das erinnert sie auch an ihre schweizer
heimatstadt mich als kämpferin
was ich an genf am meisten liebe sind
die natur drumherum unseren hausberg den
salat
es gibt es hier nicht was ich aber hier
so liebe ist diese weite und diese große
räumlichkeit
[Musik]
bis vor zehn jahren bin ich nie rad
gefahren
erst 30 jahren fingen radwege zu bauen
bin ich auf die idee gekommen
aber es ist schon ziemlich weit bis zur
botschaft nichts für jeden tag das
moskauer zentrum wurde in den letzten
jahren mächtig aufgepeppt mit
fahrradstrecken und fußgängerzonen aber
viele kleine geschäfte und märkte wurden
von den behörden teils gewaltsam
entfernt
[Musik]
früher gab es hier einen großen markt
den haben sie geräumt
das war wirklich eine enttäuschung
zwischen dorotheas wohnung und der
arbeit liegt der fluss moskwa kein
großes hindernis
theoretisch dürfte ich ja hier nicht
fahren aber ich war ganz ruhig sie sagen
unfalls steige ich dann ab jetzt sind
wir ganz nahe bei der botschaft noch
fünf minuten zurück in der provinz auf
der baustelle von roland lay
der 61 jährige macht regelmäßig
kontrollen vor ort zeit für eine
besprechung mit seinen bauleitern den
wichtigsten leuten wenn roland nicht da
ist
einige mitarbeiter arbeiten seit über 20
jahren für sein unternehmen kontinuität
zählt die baubranche ist ein komplexes
geschäft in russland erst recht
rechtssicherheit und alles ist jedoch
nicht vergleichbar natürlich ganz
wichtig als sie auf jeder baustelle
bauleiter der man gerne vertrauen will
die hände hoch verantwortet aber die
echte probleme sehe man nur beim aufbau
stellt der liegt die tau gelagert und
selbst war auf der baustelle läuft denkt
selber problem und das ist meine devise
darum bin ich immer unterwegs immer
unterwegs und immer erreichbar
täglich noch die preise von diesen
rohren die brauche ich dringend ja weil
ich muss das morgen fertig machen am
sonntag müssen die das angebot haben das
habe ich so abgemacht es gibt natürlich
immer wieder überraschungen es laufen da
ist es so schön wie das dritte schweizer
erste station ein zementwerk ein teil
der produktionsstraße muss ausgetauscht
werden
roland ist generalunternehmer und trägt
auch die verantwortung wenn etwas schief
läuft mit der türkei angst haben von
große projekt in russland alles nicht in
größeren dimensionen
aber wo mehr abfangen händler im 3 es
geht natürlich auch andere objekt macht
ein rohr in der klinker trocknungsanlage
hat sich wegen zu großer hitze verformt
ein planungsfehler ein schaden dieser
art kann schnell sehr teuer werden
doch wer haftet es ist zum glück mit
diesem fall laxey und darum wäre für die
arbeiten zusätzlich machen
wer zahlt
also wie viel los da kann ich doch keine
christ war für schwierigkeiten ist in
russland erwartet die hat das andere
behaupten kennt die birne ob sie vorher
von drüben in ski und überlege mir sind
wachse mit aufgaben schwierigkeiten was
da wo ist täglich konfrontiert worden
sind mitten im zentrum in unmittelbarer
nähe zum kreml befindet sich die neue
heimat von svetlana guggenbühl
die top lage ihre wohnung beweist auch
beim immobilienkauf hat die
unternehmerfamilie ein geschicktes
händchen und krise vor einem tag auf den
andern sind ja ich sind immobilienpreise
um 50 prozent eingebrochen
und ja innerhalb von einer woche sind in
die mitte wo nicht sofort wachsen
solana hat hier die ersten acht jahre
ihrer kindheit verbracht ihre gesamte
jugend jedoch in der schweiz extrem mit
scharfer verwendet und nicht mit extrem
einfach labor sondern wirtschaftlich
bauer und jedes mal wenn ich das gefühl
hatte sich das will ich zu viele sachen
laufen zu groß sie starte ich bin
erschöpft
dann haben die möglichkeit einfach ein
flug zu buchen und dann bin ich
innerhalb von dreieinhalb stunden über
die geschichte und ich glaube dass ich
ein hintergedanken wenn es zufällig von
egal
das legendäre moskauer kaufhaus gum
svitlana es nicht zum shoppen hier
sondern zur recherche sie beobachtet die
entwicklungen im land sehr genau und ist
immer auf der suche nach trends dass sie
ihren business traum hier verwirklichen
will liegt daran dass der markt größer
noch nicht so übersättigt ist wie in der
schweiz
doch können sich durchschnitt saucen
ihren speciality coffee überhaupt
leisten
bevor sanktionen sind und bevor der
krise sommer kräftig ich eigentlich los
dann willkommen
maxi ausland das problem ist auch dass
es eine extrem richtig heftig und genau
die extreme armut
es geht mir jetzt nicht so sehr in der
stadt in moskau ein komischer aber
trotzdem glaube ich dass es ein linie
mittelschicht geht wo einfach besser die
wand also ich sage jetzt mit bruder aber
sie können sich bis 15 frauen guten
kaffee leistungen im instant coffee oder
wie war der sowjetunion die hand einfach
jetzt das gewisses budget wenn sie das
iphone kaufen zum instagram aber leider
zum jetzt der jugendliche ebene anlagen
oder deutschland in australien amerika
und sie dann auch ihr produkt zu können
lässt keine recherche ohne besuch in
einem der neuen coffeeshops die
jungunternehmerin weiß was sie will ist
es mein körper oder ist es nicht wenn
sie nicht mitmache dass wir großen allem
in kw wert aber ich bin mir ganz sicher
dass trainer und sportler werden
coffeeshop in russland zumindest einmal
äußerst probieren
und ich glaube das feedback von der
hunde ich habe immer die beste ihre
finanzpolitik
das zentrum von moskau ist heiß begehrt
wer hier zu sowjetzeiten eine
stadtwohnung zugeteilt bekam besitzt
heute eine wertvolle immobilie andres
eltern hatten dieses glück und sie sind
sogar bereit schüler und andere die
wohnung abzutreten
[Musik]
die schwiegereltern ziehen dafür in
gillies alte wohnung der grund für den
tausch nach den ferien kommt schließt
tochter wäre in die schule ganz in der
nähe
bis dahin muss jedoch noch einiges getan
werden
ein handwerker team aus der ukraine
saniert die wohnung zu einem festpreis
so können andré und willi sicher sein
dass sie ihre arbeit so zügig wie
möglich erledigen und das mit den
entsprechenden schwierigkeiten und
probleme und da extrem froh dass mir der
schweizer familie bibliothek für die
wand die sowjetunion hatte ich extrem
wichtige also extrem wichtiges ski und
dann ist das stolz vor der familie
er zeigt dass man politisch und das ist
immer noch wichtig weil danksin ist das
erwähnen bedenklich dass die viren ist
in der krise und amiga spd stand für den
fußboden haben sich die zwei für echte
entschieden
das klingt luxuriöser als es tatsächlich
ist
also ich mir sagen dass in russland der
preis im vergleich zur europa führt mal
mindestens fünf mal niedriger ist und
wir haben dabei auch die einfachste
sorte ausgewählt weil es eben natürlich
mit all diesen löchern steht uns das
verkauft hatte war völlig schockiert
dass wir genau solche warnhinweise
verkaufen ist auch die sache nicht runde
oder hat gesagt normalerweise zu hause
und dem campus kommt aus dem kaukasus
macht er schläge drauf schweizer anders
statement ungewohnt für moskau in der
kategorie der meisten milliardäre liegt
die russische hauptstadt hinter new york
mittlerweile auf rang zwei ganz so
weiter dass mit lana gucken will mit
ihrem café start noch nicht gebracht
doch die ehrgeizige unternehmerin
arbeitet daran
ein enormer vorteil ihr freund tieren
ist zugleich auch ihr geschäftspartner
[Musik]
swetlana hat in ihrer jugend
professionell getanzt und an diversen
europa und weltmeisterschaften
teilgenommen
beeindruckend findet erst kürzlich war
es mit lana wieder aktiv als promi coach
in der srf tanzshow darf ich bitten
[Musik]
momentan tanzschritt lager nicht mehr
professionell
denn so ein hochleistungssport braucht
zeit und einen tanzpartner beides fehlt
dir doch seitdem tanzen viel zu
verdanken
das ist immer noch drauf maximum level
sie das hat schon sehr viel disziplin
fördere und er geht und kompetitiv dank
haben wir im rat turniersieger
weltmeisterschaft und
europameisterschaft und allem und es hat
natürlich so in ganz sachsen als er
trägt sicher hilft ihr das um in der
geschäftswelt moskaus erfolgreich zu
werden
[Musik]
wer die berufliche herausforderung sucht
wird in der millionenmetropole sicher
fündig gespannter erwartung im hotel
metropol
heute soll der besitzer selber
vorbeikommen ein russischer milliardär
und erfolgreicher immobilien händler
da muss alles stimmen
[Musik]
die damals halt jetzt natürlich der
atome von wird natürlich mal richtiges
nicht wenn man so seitdem sitzen
ermöglichen hitzewelle natürlich
spitzenmanagement ein bekanntes solid
und qualität und vertrauen dass dann
schluss stimmt neu organisiert hat oder
auch den service
ein sowjetischer offizier sohn führt
jetzt das kommando
wir sind alle regionen und dürfen
reservierte richtige organisation
[Musik]
das schon wichtig wir werden aber genau
gleich laufen und entsprechend hätte das
schon positiv los das ist ein nach einer
richtig funktioniert die letzten details
nimmt oder selbst in die hand
wir dürfen ab diesem moment nur noch die
musiker filmen aber auf keinen fall den
hotelbesitzer der milliardär gilt das
sehr kamera und interviews
[Musik]
willi berchtold ist auf dem weg zu ihrer
tochter auf die datscha mit der
regionalbahn geht's am schnellsten die
straßen aus moskau raus sind am
freitagabend immer verstopft weil übers
wochenende alle aufs land fahren
an dieser tradition hat sich nichts
geändert
[Musik]
gk sehr lang so viel können durch das
einschlagen auf
es ist möglich es jetzt luftschlacht ist
und ihr mann andré ist schon vorgefahren
tochter vera verbringt ohnehin den
ganzen sommer auf der datscha die
unterbringung bei den großeltern auf dem
land ist in russland nichts
ungewöhnliches dass die sechsjährige
sich auf die mama freut hört man schon
von weitem
auch hunt rem und schwiegervater sascha
gehören zum begrüßungskomitee juli ist
im wahrsten sinne angekommen und der
alltagsstress kann draußen bleiben
[Musik]
wichtig ist nur dass auch im moment aber
unter zwei jahren die helfer blatter und
das land ja und da ich kein trainer mehr
grün kombiniert
das ist vielleicht finden wir hier
besser geht aus dem beispiel schweiz
fort so lagert ist bis zu einer stelle
die lässt ihr trainer ist es natürlich
super es ist wirklich frei bewegen im
gegensatz zu moskau war immer wieder
beobachten zu müssen b- c- und hängen
nach allofs' und logen das nicht
passiert hat sich hier wirkte absolut
die freiheit selbst freunde hier was
spielt und die sascha der schwiegervater
der touran im garten und webtv vorweisen
das ist super alle genießen die
ländliche idylle auf den autobahnen um
moskau hingegen dass der teufel los wer
um diese zeit noch im auto unterwegs ist
endet meist im stau bauunternehmer
roland lay ist täglich und rot er kennt
das problem und fahrerseite zum glück
die nötigen schleichwege
wenn man mitten im großen stil auf die
straße die sind viel sport plus nur
erstaunt spur
denn es macht man sich halt irgendwo der
weg wo es um schnellster gott und
vordringlich sei bisher sehr gut kennt
da ist das doch ein volkssport auch seit
beherrscht das gut und so ist holland
bald zu hause
er bewohnt im wohn und geschäftsvierteln
yukos abba naor einer partner hoch über
den dächern der stadt seine freundin
katja ist bereits auf der gemeinsamen
deutscher doch roland koch gerne auch
für sich alleine beim kochen machen der
wege riesen server reichen meine
freundin die muss immer alles auf putzen
roland hat für seine karriere seine
erste ehefrau sowie die beiden
gemeinsamen söhne verlassen gibt ihm der
erfolg im nachhinein recht das ist
relativ wohl die meine natürlich im
business sitze so der region uni tätig
sie wie sich das objekt trainer machen
wir jetzt da in russland alleine machen
aber du zahlst für alles was du machst
ist dass die straße vor allem der
pflicht das ist verrückt das macht
anfällig
die wirtschaftskrise hat auch das
baugeschäft getroffen
roland kennt zwar das auf und ab in
russland doch der druck ist enorm
das problem ist dass im moment der ewf
trikot slow food und musik mit der sachs
hat dafür und die westliche firmen sind
im moment mit investitionen in russland
sehr zurückhaltend das spüren wir
natürlich das strategische durch das man
viel aktiver akquisition betrieb wie
vorher
früher haben wir das problem die meisten
shows live draco bevor andrea cosic sie
sind und dass ich immer mit mini
christoph kopp und auch die gerüchte
sorgt damit die kein lügner sind klo vor
allem nicht vor der langjährige
mitarbeiter darum bin ich im moment
ziemlich unter druck wegen der affäre
[Musik]
dorothea hatte einen anstrengenden tag
ihr büro liegt ganz am ende des gebäudes
der schweizer botschaft man muss auch
noch durch die militär sektion um zu mir
zu kommen
ich glaube er war mal die wohnung eines
diplomaten oder das botschafters aus dem
buch das badezimmer die küche und hier
sitzen valentina und ich das entspannte
umfeld in ihrem büro hat sie bewusst
gewählt
dorothea setzt in russland schweizer
menschenrechts projekte um eine
schwierige mission
ich spüre dass sich die menschen hier
wohlfühlen
ich treffe manchmal menschen aus
bestimmten regionen russlands die zuerst
sehr verschlossen sind
hier öffnen sie sich und reden es ist
ruhig aber ich behalte das natürlich für
mich ich erzähle nicht gleich alles
weiter
nein das ist für unsere
hintergrundwissen um die regionen besser
zu verstehen
diese figuren dort oben wurden in
gefängnissen hergestellt das haftsystem
ist sehr hart und noch aus der
sowjetzeit klar gibt es anstalten in
denen es besser und solche in denen es
schlechter ist dorothea war in den
letzten jahren für ein gefängnis
programm mit verantwortlich dabei halfen
schweizer experten den russischen
strafvollzug zu reformieren
mehr ausbildungszentren statt reiner
strafkolonie das war das ziel den jungen
häftlingen später den einstieg in die
arbeitswelt erleichtern um sie besser in
die gesellschaft integrieren zu können
[Musik]
naja was in den russischen gefängnissen
interessant ist sind die vielen
künstlerischen aktivitäten
davon zeigten sich die schweizer
experten beeindruckt wir haben in den
letzten jahren vor allem in den
jugendhaftanstalten gearbeitet das mag
vielleicht jetzt schockierend wirken
aber ich glaube für manche jugendliche
ist es besser wenn sie im gefängnis
sitzen
manche von ihnen kommen aus völlig
zerstörten familien
sie gehen jahre lang nicht zur schule
sie ernähren sich schlecht die haben
kein bett sie sind verwahrloste
jugendliche
[Musik]
abend dessen vorbereitung auf der
datscha ganz traditionell schaschlik auf
offenen grill bei dieser landestypischen
spezialitäten aus alles seine
richtigkeit haben
findet zumindest schwiegervater sascha
und spießt das fleisch noch einmal
richtig auf
meistens einig dass die großeltern sich
in russland mehr in das leben ihrer
kinder einmischen liegt an der kultur
auch große kinder sind und bleiben leben
kinder
wir sagen immer wenn jemand aus der
älteren generation stirbt es dann wirst
du richtig erwachsen und das kann erst
sehr spät passieren wenn deine eltern
aber noch leben
dann spielt es keine rolle wie alt du
bist du fühlt dass er noch einer auf
sich aufpasst dass russische klischee
ist hier gelebte realität
familienzusammenhalt über die
generationen hinweg
lebensfroh und gastfreundlich genießt
juli mit ihrer familie das wochenende
auf der datscha dass sie us bernerin
ihre eigene familie in der schweiz
hinten anstellen muss fällt dir aber
nicht immer leicht
[Musik]
das macht nix sind dadurch bezahlt oder
nizza oder wir immer dass es so nach
häusern in der antrag meiner haut ist
mit skype und setzt mit der schule mit
der lokalbesitzer organisierte designer
und den bewegungslos die vier jahre mit
dieser bahn archiv
wer sein glück in der fremde sucht macht
die lieben daheim immer ein bisschen
unglücklich in der nächsten folge großes
oldtimer rallye am metropol direktor
dominique fouda wird zum co-piloten
außerdem willis tochter vera zu besuch
bei der großmutter in der schweiz leider
ohne mama
doch zum glück gibt es keine
und endlich da für lorenz und seine
familie beginnt das abenteuer moskau
neues land neues leben
ob alles klappt